you are an actual fan of martin freeman
i'm a huge fan of mineframe oh thank you
it's all right and a huge trend
you're trying to name it
yeah i'm a huge fan of everyone um
but
everyone's equal everyone's equal but
some people are more equal than others
no i was a huge fan of the office like i
still am a huge fan but when i was at
university we used to watch the office
we had the dvd we'd watch it every day
and i found i thought tim was really
cool oh nice yeah and there's a scene
where you go to chase's nightclub yeah
and uh yeah tim's dancing and i used to
think it was the coolest dancing i'd
ever seen really i had a bottle of beer
and i was yeah yeah oh he's doing it
it's just that yeah just like you look
really bored i did i was i was eye
stroke tim was bored and embarrassed
yeah and i i tried to like adopt your
dance while i was at uni really when i
was out on the pool
and
nothing
i'm sorry
maybe if you'd dance like they would
drink when it would have been better
[Music]